only on CBS this morning we spoke to the
parents of a British motorcycle was
killed by an American driver in a
wrong-way crash in the UK 19 year old
Harry Dunne died in August when he was
hit by a car the driver was Ansah khulus
an American whose husband worked at the
base
she left the UK after claiming
diplomatic immunity but in a statement
her lawyer says so culus would like to
meet with Harry Dunn's parents we spoke
to his parents Charlotte and Tim earlier
this morning about whether they want
that to happen
you don't hope to meet her while you're
here in the United States I don't see
what we would gain from that if it was a
few weeks back but we're you know we're
one week off from being two months now
you know so we are still very open to
meeting her but it needs to be in a
controlled environment in the UK you
don't want to meet here in the United
States is what you're saying we've been
advised that wouldn't be the best thing
for us to do and I think we need
counselors and therapy therapists around
us we all of our grief has gone on hold
it's coming out in other horrific ways
like your legs feel like lead and you in
pain morning morning tonight that no
painkillers can take away hmm you're not
able to cry because we can't understand
this whole situation as to why she would
have left us without wanting to meet us
back then it's just she needs to get on
the plane she needs to go back to the UK
it's it's to just do the right thing it
shouldn't be that difficult it shouldn't
have been this difficult
she didn't Shirley didn't have to go
although we believe she may not have
been given a choice if the diplomatic
immunity cloak had been put around her
because it's now turned into a
diplomatic incident you're saying you
don't think it needed to be that what do
you what would have made you be you're
never okay with the death of your son
but well what would you like to have
seen have happened just
stay in the UK meet us we've been very
very open right from the start with the
UK police Northampton share police the
if she'd have stayed in the UK knowing
that she was a parent herself we'd
agreed as a family that we would have
done all we could didn't we yet her
death by dangerous driving that they
wanted to pursue her for reduced to
death by careless driving and try and
get her a suspended sentence so that we
didn't take her away from her children
you were okay with that we were with
that we're not spending any time and
behind me absolutely because we heard we
didn't realise but there was children in
the car when she had the accident so as
soon as we heard that we were like oh
well well you know because we been
parents you know what it's like you
don't think he wanted to take their
mother away from their children and we
really honestly mean now but she can't
just walk away it's been a report that
she did cooperate with authorities in
the beginning and she's not sure what
when she left or why she left we do not
know that we don't know that I just win
what's his twins name nyow nyow how was
that I was drifting no thanks today like
we are literally hour by hour
we're just taking things one hour at a
time we can't think any further ahead
than that so what do you hope what do
you hope to accomplish coming to the US
what what is your purpose to come here
well we need so we just wanted to come
to speak to you guys to put our story
out there to let the American people
know what it's actually going on and we
just just tell people about Harry and
how we just want our justice for our son
you know what do you want us to know
about Harry and what does justice look
like for you I know when the death of a
child I would think there isn't any
closure it's a matter of not moving on
but moving forward yes so what do you
want us to know about Harry and what
does justice look like for the two of
you he was amazing
that's he was that amazing dad with a
big heart
yeah
lots and lots of people loved him and he
loved them equally back if anyone was in
trouble he had their back if anyone he
felt was in the wrong he would stand up
and speak openly and try and get things
sorted out and make them do the right
thing and that's the legacy that he's
left us to do where we're honoring him
yes you were certified to do this you
know your bottom line is you would like
her to come back to the three words to
do the right thing you know just do the
right thing are you asking for jail time
now I don't think it's I don't think
we're gonna have any choice now because
we're seven weeks on and it's taken her
all this time to come forward I'm not
sure whether the police are going to
allow us to intervene now if we can we
will work with them but it may be taken
out with our hands now we don't know
where we stand with that Charlotte
Charles and Tim Dunn and the way I began
I'm so sorry and I thank you so much for
joining us here thank you thank you yes
thank you thank you oh you know it was
very tough there was a big picture of
Harry on the wall on his motorcycle and
it was touching to see them stand
looking at their son going you know
that's our boy he was an amazing boy
there are just no winners here you I
think about an cyclist is a terrible
terrible accident they all agree on that
so I'm sure it's devastating for her as
well which is what her lawyer said
nobody wins here but the family is
clearly saying they came to America
because they want the American people
know it's getting a lot of coverage in
the UK as well and they're starting to
get angry though guys were a little more
forgiving now they're starting to get a
little angry you feel for them that they
have to be here to be heard that's what
they said whatever and I'm sure we'll be
covering it yes